the things that get us and others
sexually excited often sound rather
improbable and mysterious yet beneath
the surface
many of our erotic enthusiasms are
motivated by something very touching and
very same a desire for total closeness
take BDSM there's huge pressure in our
society to be independent and strong and
yet inside us some of us are deeply
attracted to and therefore also turned
on by the counterbalancing thought of
Thoreau passivity and Submission as a
form of escape from the over strenuous
demands of grown-up life the wish to be
a slave means that someone else will
know exactly what you should do and take
all choice away from you this could
sound appalling because most slave
owners we can imagine indeed most
authority figures are pretty awful we so
badly want to be independent in part
because there doesn't seem to be anyone
around nice enough to deserve our weak
ourselves but the deeper hope which can
come out in sex is that we would be with
someone who could be worthy of a
complete loyalty and devotion as for the
dominant partner there's an analogous
dynamic at work modern life generally
demands extreme politeness and restraint
we have to keep our bossiness in check
but in our hearts we might think we know
exactly what someone else really needs
we might like to be quite bossy and
enforce absolute obedience we just lack
the necessary authority and power in the
real world so the exciting fantasy is
that someone will at last acknowledge
our strength and wisdom will recognize
our talents and will put us wholly in
charge of them no more need for the
skepticism about who we are and
therefore no more restraint no more need
to hold our tongue the games of
submission and domination offer
opportunities to investigate wishes that
are far from being simply peculiar
pointless or even
slightly demented they offer brief
utopian interludes in which we can with
a rare and real friend safely cast off
our normal defenses and share and
satisfy our longings for extreme
closeness and mutual acceptance which is
the real psychologically rooted reason
why these games are so exciting
you